there's a lot of young moms out here and
they you know they can only get work
making so much and for it to be hundreds
of dollars for a week worth of child
care i mean it's insane jan senn a
grandmother who knows all too well about
the struggles her own daughter has
endured she along with several others
pleased with these new funds now
available to low to middle class income
families chelsea slider works for the
children's cabinet a non-profit
organization that works closely with the
las vegas urban league together they
offer a variety of child care services
for southern nevada families we see
people every day come through our doors
that are
barely making it or they're not making
ends meet you know they're barely
getting by so this is going to provide a
huge amount of financial
stress relief for our families over at
mommy's angels child care on rainbow
boulevard manager rick farage says
there's a big demand for infant and
toddler care and while they have plans
in place to help parents financially
sometimes it's not enough we have some
parents that they don't honestly they
don't have the money it's not like
they're trying to save the money they
don't have the money and their rights
stuck between
if i'm gonna stay home to watch my kid i
can't afford
to pay rent and so on
and while there was already a program in
place for low-income families it should
be clear that the relief is now expanded
to those in the middle income range
making up to 70 thousand dollars per
year per family now for details on where
to apply you can head to our website at
8newsnow.com in the newsroom madison
kimbrough live local now